now to a dramatic move by the federal
reserve to try to stop the surge in
inflation that's affecting every
american family stocks jumped yesterday
in response to the biggest hike in
interest rates in nearly 30 years three
quarters of a percentage point carter
evans is following all of this from los
angeles carter good morning
good morning michelle the interest rate
that we're talking about here it's
called the federal funds rate now this
is what the government charges banks to
borrow money loan rates for consumers
are going to be even more expensive
because of course those banks need to
make money themselves the idea is that
if you make that money more expensive to
borrow people won't spend as much
hopefully bringing prices back down to
earth
we're strongly committed to bringing
inflation back down
and we're moving expeditiously to do so
the last time the fed raised rates this
dramatically was in 1994 when inflation
was only at 2.7 percent last month it
surged to 8.6
despite the bold action the central bank
can only do so much i think that events
of the last few months
have raised the degree of difficulty
there's a much bigger chance now that
it'll depend on factors that we don't
control
like a war in ukraine and a pandemic
that roiled the economy i had two jobs
and money was great but
thanks a lot to over 19 you killed that
this 47-year-old single mother in
pasadena california now relies on a food
bank is it hard to make ends meet yes it
is
and she's considering leaving the state
to escape the skyrocketing cost of
living i love the state of california
don't get me wrong
but the tides have turned
like
we have to migrate so far interest rates
are up one and a half percent this year
that means a loan for the average new
car price of 47 thousand dollars will
cost almost sixty dollars a month more
in interest than last year and more
expensive loans could discourage
spending which will reduce the
insatiable demand now driving inflation
to 40-year highs all these loans are
going to get more and more expensive cbs
news analyst jill schlesinger says it's
time for americans to start saving and
paying off debt the best thing you can
do is try to pay down those kinds of
rates that adjust when interest rates
adjust
if the economy were to slow down if a
recession were to occur it's always good
to have those emergency reserve funds
beefed up
and think about this borrowing is just
going to keep getting more expensive
this is not the end of the rate hikes
next month expect another half to
three-quarter point increase and by the
end of the year the central bank right
now is predicting the fed funds rate
could be as high as 3.4 that's a lot
higher than it is right now tony
wow carter and fed chairman jerome
powell is saying he does not want to
induce a recession he's trying to be
clear about that but these moves could
bring one on